[Music]
foreign
ivan lee welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you thanks for having me on how
are you doing where are you calling from
i am reaching you from sunnyvale
california today sunnyvale california
okay so not too far i'm in southern
california
and are you keeping healthy everything
everybody's okay
yeah things are going all right finding
my own new daily routines
um yeah adjusting to the new norm i'm
sure and i'm sure that having an early
stage startup with
this new norm is is quite challenging
even though you're a software platform
i'm sure it still has its challenges so
i'd love for you to give a little bit of
a background about yourself
just as a quick spoiler you know product
management at
yahoo and apple uh you sold the company
to a yahoo before
and now you're a ceo of data soar
so ivan where do you come from
what excites you sure um so i'll give my
my quick background in a nutshell here
um i grew up outside of seattle
i came down here for school um studied
computer science at stanford for
undergrad
um and i was starting my masters there
as well uh but as is stanford tradition
i dropped out
and started a video game company with
some friends i've been a lifelong gamer
and so it was always a childhood dream
to build that out
had a ton of fun with it built out a
profitable game and ultimately sold the
company to yahoo in 2013.
what are your favorite games my favorite
games
um right now i've been playing you know
to this day i still play league of
legends but i grew up playing smash
brothers halo age of empires
how do you balance that with it with a
ceo position
it's you know i think it's really
important for ceos to have hobbies to
help keep them sane
um so league for me is is a social
outlet works really well on quarantine
um other than that i actually still play
ultimate frisbee at the stanford oval
every single sunday
and so that's kept being seen for the
last decade oh wow okay that's that's
pretty incredible
so tell me you know a little bit about
this this interesting
experience you've had being moving from
a ceo of a company of a gaming company
to then being
a product manager at yahoo and apple how
was that transition for you
i was actually really grateful to have
the full spectrum of experiences
um starting your own company
you have to figure out how to do things
on your own that was my first real job
right outside of internships
and so you know we were for engineers
straight out of school
i had to basically reinvent the wheel on
what product management meant for our
company
and i'm somebody who learns by doing so
that was an interesting first start
obviously made a ton of mistakes but
when i arrived at yahoo
i was really lucky to be part of the apm
program the associate product managers
program there
and they gave me training on how a
professional does it right
and what that allows allowing me to do
is pick and choose and say well
i like the way i did things better on
these fronts but i also really like
learning how professionals have
approached this problem in this way
and so that gave me the the perspective
to
to balance out you know my personal
learnings with
what others have institutionalized and
said this is how things should be done
at large successful companies
and was it a similar learning experience
between
apple and yahoo or did you find that
things were radically different between
the two
uh certainly very different i think that
different companies
not only different companies but even
down to the organization the manager
that you have
you will just find completely different
experiences at companies
right so yeah between between yahoo and
apple i still had
a diverse set of experiences yeah i
think it's
always interesting for me to to sort of
understand these differences and
and know that there is no you know white
glove that fits every hand
where you have one playbook as a product
management i'm
experimenting now in in a company that i
work for with product management
and i see all these different
challenging sources
and there is no one one said rule but
what are some of your key takeaways
from these two times if you were the
advice you would give
any product manager at any company
oh man so i think in addition to the
fact that different companies and
organizations are different it gets even
trickier when you talk about product
management in particular
because just by definition the the pm
job
is one that varies completely from
from team to team and you need to
fill in different roles no matter where
you go right
and so i guess if there's one key
takeaway um
i'm a big believer in servant leadership
right this is this is a philosophy
that that many articles have been
written about but
in particular when it comes to product
management
success is defined by being able to
enable your team
making sure that your engineers are
unblocked making sure that your
designers uh
are connected with the business
objectives
of the broader team right and so
whatever
you know whatever organization or team
you're joining i think it's
important to just dig in and figure out
how can i best um
enable and support this team and throw
away
all previous conceptions of like what a
pm was at your previous job
yeah i think that that's that's very
interesting take on you know
looking at a pm as a leadership role and
understanding that as you transition
between teams which is inevitable
you need to put on these different hats
and empathize with the people that
you're working with and the product
you're working on
and i'm sure that it's also extremely
different between you know when you're
doing something for
an enterprise team versus a b2c
team which is also fascinating so let's
move on to
artificial intelligence labeling nlp
data soar yeah so
um actually segwaying into that topic um
the reason that i ended up working on
machine learning and ai in the first
place is because
my manager understood that you know i
had a lot of experience as a front-end
pm um i like thinking about design
and user experience and all of that but
i had no experience on a backup so he
assigned me
to replace you know yahoo's 15 year old
search algorithms with a machine learned
model
and my team was able to accomplish that
you know within a matter of months and
that blew my mind
and so that changed the trajectory of my
career um i i was no longer working in
games i became an mlpm for the next
seven years
right wow okay yeah so that was a really
meaningful transition
um and so yeah i became a convert this
was early on in the ai hype cycle as
well
yeah i came to better understand just
how powerful
uh you know ai technology could be
but i also got a peek behind the scenes
as to how all this works
and it turns out you know in order to
power all these ai algorithms you need
a lot a lot of uh training data
you need to feed it a lot of examples so
they can learn and build an
understanding of our world
and and expectations of our world right
and so
um having experienced that and having
spent millions of dollars getting
labeled data over the years
instead of you know recreating these
processes
um yet again at another company i
decided it was better for me to just
build a startup around this and say
let's solve this for for the industry
once and for all
and so that was the origin of datasore a
little over a year ago i started this
company
with the goal of taking all these best
practices all the solutions that i'd
seen you know reinventing the wheel over
and over again at multiple companies
democratize that and make that available
to anyone working on
on aai right so so data labeling
why is it difficult why does it cost
millions of dollars
yeah give me the broader spectrum about
this sure
so it's a it's a volume it's a volume
thing
right it can be very difficult at times
it doesn't
always have to be but essentially
algorithms have a really like
human still have an advantage over these
these robotic algorithms in that we come
with
you know this wealth of experience in
the real world we have subjective
opinions
so i'll give you one example right think
about yelp reviews
you want to understand whether the
reviewer is saying something positive or
negative about things
right people will employ sarcasm they'll
employ you know
all kinds of of linguistic tactics to
to write their review and it's not
always straightforward to understand
so you need to feed the model
lots of these examples so it can begin
to understand
um exactly how humans describe in this
case
restaurants yeah you know one of the
things that i always alluded to when i
when i think of nlp
it's and the difference between just
understanding the content of what we're
saying but also the
intent and i think of the onion
and if i were to give you know a a
computer
and a regular machine learning algorithm
you know 10 years 10 or 15 years ago
a piece of the onion to read it would
probably be able to
to understand the content they would
take it seriously and i imagine then a
leader
making decisions based on the onion that
would be pretty funny and pretty sad at
the same time
and i think that's exact for me that's
the distinction with what nlp is really
about understanding the intent behind
what the person was writing yeah that's
a wonderful example
great so so okay labeling volumes costs
a lot
how do you actually democratize that and
help solve that
right so i think the other thing to
understand is everybody at this point
has heard
in the mainstream media all these
advances in ai right like we're
we're well into the ai hype cycle but
the thing is
um deployment is not fully out there
uh we're still very early in the
adoption cycle
and so if you think about fortune you
know 500 companies we
were thinking about traditional uh
industries like agriculture
foresting oil right they may have
allocated budgets
towards uh deploying ai but
we're it's far from being ubiquitous so
far
so i think we are um
because there is still so much adoption
left
to be done in the coming decade uh
i wanted datasource to be well
positioned to be the data labeling
um solution of of choice right
now as far as democratizing it uh
all these companies you know the googles
and the facebooks and the apples of the
world they're building their own
internal tooling right
but as somebody who you know comes from
an engineering background as a product
manager i see that purely as an
inefficiency
why is everyone rebuilding very similar
tools if you had a designer today
you wouldn't say oh let me go build this
you know tool to help them design better
you just buy photoshop or sketch or
figma right
similarly i want people to get to the
point where if you have data labelers
you shouldn't be thinking of building
your own solution which is
the the standard in industry today you
should come to datasore and say oh
well obviously i should just use this
pre-existing solution
so now here's my question and i'm
challenging a little bit because it's
i'm curious when you make the analogy
for photoshop and figment all those
you know there are 20 year old softwares
that have potentially thousands of
engineers behind them
yet you need to generate revenue
tomorrow to be able to raise your series
a
and then my question is so how how do
you do that because
if you go to the googles and facebooks
with you know an mvp
then they'll say ah our internal tool is
well it's not good it still
gives it's still better and more it's
more specific
to us and startups may not have the
funds to pay for this so how do you
actually
go about bringing this to market until
it gets to the level of photoshop
yeah it's a great question and i think
that is part of you know every startup's
journey
is like how do you compete against you
know sometimes much better resource
teams
in this case we're fortunate um you know
we i've had a peek
at some of the tools that some of our
clients have been building out and
the thing is i've got seven wonderful
engineers who've been working on
at this non-stop for the past year and
our solution is
you know arguably the best and most
comprehensive one out there from a
generic standpoint right like it is
already it has already surpassed
what these teams have sometimes spent
years building out internally
yeah and the reason is this right if
you're if you're working at
apple and you want to and you've got
some good engineers
you don't necessarily prioritize their
time to work on internal tooling
you'll have them working on improving
ios right like some of the main product
lines
and so our competition isn't always the
entire organization we're competing
against
oh this engineer had a few extra cycles
here and there
right now that makes a lot of sense and
actually when you boil it down then
let's say a company
a a huge company puts you know even 50
people on this task
they're working at the speed of a
corporation whereas if you have
you know 10 people working at the speed
of a startup then that's that's a much
easier comparison that that's in your
favor that makes a lot of sense
so you know let's take me down take me
down the road of data sore
you know five ten years from now and
alongside
what is happening to nlp and artificial
intelligence
and where are you positioned with that
yeah
um well five to ten years is a long long
time in
in the world of tech right that's what
you're committed to no
it is it is but i also think about
things this is the product manager at me
i think about things one
step at a time right so um let's talk
more about
short-term goals for for the time being
in the next year or two
i want to be that de facto standard for
nlp labeling right if you have
uh nlp labeling to be done you should
just immediately think of data store and
say well
yeah we should definitely use that tool
so we want to make sure we focus
on nailing that use case first and
foremost beyond that
there are different avenues that we can
go down right we can
um work into work our way into other
media verticals as well
so for example audio has a lot of
synergies and we're seeing with you know
in
in-house living room assistance like
siri and alexa
we're seeing a lot of advances in voice
technology as well yeah well what
happens once you've transcribed these
these voice transcripts right you'll
want to do the same types of labeling
that you do with text you still want to
detect that sarcasm you still want to
detect the entities so there's that's a
natural extension for us
and really once we have our foot in the
door and we have companies coming to us
for training
that training data to build their model
we can maybe help them with other
elements of building the model as well
yeah and i think your experience is is
pretty extraordinary for the
circumstance of what you're doing given
that you
you've done you're an engineer by
profession you went on to become to
founding a company selling that company
going through that whole phase
product management in two large
companies
with machine learning background and now
doing this knowing the tools that are
internal
and having experienced them yourself so
i i mean i vouch for this
and myself you have something also
that's special about your team that's
not
very common to silicon valley right um
in the way that your team is actually
not in silicon valley a lot of them
that's true so tell me about that so how
is that
yeah um i'm just in a really i was in a
really fortunate spot when i started
this company
um i was able to start this with five
engineers right off the bat
um so my team as you are leading
alluding to uh they're actually
based in indonesia and so we have a
fully remote team
um and even within indonesia you know
they're based in three or four different
cities
so we are by our very nature distributed
um i thought that this would be more of
an anomaly
um i thought this would raise a lot more
eyebrows with investors
but you know having gone through the
recent y combinator batch
having spoken with investors this is
becoming the new norm
uh you know it's
there's so much demand for for engineers
in silicon valley that it's becoming
very difficult for startups to get the
right engineering talent here
and it's a global economy in a global
world right and so we've been operating
remotely from day one
and it's worked out really well for us
so far yeah and i think i think
the real test is time and i'm sure that
as you go through y combinator
raise your your recent round and you're
showing the results of what your remote
team has done i think that's amazing
and i'm guessing then that you're pretty
thankful for having this
remote team that's very efficient in the
times of corona right when a lot of
companies are struggling moving remote
now by force
you did it by design previously
that's right 100 ivan three words
that describe you best oh man
um all right so i was thinking about
this from the start
uh i think
three words to describe me right not the
company describe you if i were to ask
anybody around you what is ivan like
what are the three
characteristics that are most important
to him
okay
i think loyalty loyalty empathy
nice and is that from the product
management side
the empathy i think it's from multiple
facets of my life
um and then the last one i would choose
is is playful
love it ivan thank you so much
thank you michael this is wonderful
great and a pleasure